the Reverend no how are you sir Jesse
Jackson welcome how are you
now I've seen you I met you yesterday
very very briefly and nobody knew that
you were coming to the building so
you're in you're in here at serious two
days in a row so are you promoting
something for more than Mark Thompson
what brings you to serious
well we're communicating the current
political climate which is horrendous in
so many ways are you pro or anti Trump
it's a great question chef that's it's
really your justice Wow
Pro fairness poor inclusion this speaks
for itself
is there anything and I asked we
interviewed Trump once I asked him to is
anything about Obama he liked was there
anything about that you think that Trump
has done well relying in the art form
you know it is striking to me that he
has dumbed down our expectations but
quite apart from his maneuvering as he
does when you have because as citizens
united with the rich invested much they
want on a given district then you have
gerrymandering upheld we make you can
draw lines so in Virginia one but 20,000
votes he lost one flip of the coin okay
since that wickedly exists WikiLeaks I
see what do you think is that what do
you think is the way to combat what's
going on with Trump because we've
watched people recently kind of try to
take some of that toxicity right that
he's brought in and try to hit him back
with the same energy and it's like what
now we're just in this sort of circle of
everybody doing what everybody says that
they don't want to be doing and it's not
working the most fun moving walked into
his vote in great numbers with passion
November the six I suppose makes America
raise their right to fight for the right
I was earlier just not to go down where
he is
the Eagles getting the fight which
snakes us all
he goes falling he shouldn't be done in
the first place what was it about Trump
that he did that made you go like I see
you I know what you're doing this is not
right well you made the move on the
rocks berth someplace simple Rock was
not an American I had known Trump some
years before as a boxing fans what about
you Fred a decent guy but then when the
Central Park five of these kids were
accused of killing of raping the womanís
they did not do and he just said they
should be executed and then when they
were set free to this she'll be executed
that was a sign yeah that was probably
not the best thing that he's done no not
the great that was Planet the best dance
that those guys that was a thing and
then of course who brought was not in
the American right didn't discredit him
in that way and I could tell the
response of those who did not vote for
him
Hospital dr. King on civil rights they
went along with that
the in charlottesville when he equated
the the civil rights marches with the
Nazis in the KKK in shell Israel
it's a it just kind of keeps on going
does it shock you like what do you
attribute the support that he gets to
does it shock you the amount of support
that Trump has based on what you see in
many ways the civil wars all over after
all the the the Jefferson Davis South
the Confederate south never gave up on
on denying public accommodation never
stopped giving up on denied the right to
vote he tapped into into their fear so
the irony is that those in the South who
now saw anti-civil rights have been the
biggest beneficiaries you couldn't have
the curl on the pounds until on the
Falcons behind the cotton curtain you
can have the Dallas Cowboys behind the
cotton you couldn't have South Carolina
and that's number one state producing
tires behind the cotton curtain the
whole new south economic reconstruction
because civil rights movement hit the
brain down various and yet they and when
when Georgia and Alabama played the big
football game generally the first you
can affair that behind and then the Old
South because we couldn't have set the
plate they work together and so they
have kind of
blue economics in red politics is
strange blue economics the accepted
economic growth in red politics and you
used to you marched in the South how did
you meet Martin Luther King jr. when I
grew up in Greenville South Carolina I
was arrested in 1960 ten years of public
library we were in the wave of surest
resistance to the radical racial
segregation his voice he merged as a
minister who had a rationale for why Jim
Crow at the end after all between 1882
1958 five thousand blocks were Lynch
five without one indictment we were
driven north as refugees do not the
south but we will draw the populations
in South Carolina and Alabama in
Arkansas in Mississippi there's a rendus
place to live in so many ways and so in
dr. King's voice took on the meeting for
us as a man who could articulate the
case I remember coming to Atlanta speak
at Morehouse College and as I was coming
to the airport he was coming all the way
to get his Nobel Peace Prize
Wow that was a big deal he spoke to me
called my name I had been in jail in
Greensboro North Carolina and found use
public accommodations and he recognized
me from having to leave that protest so
he had this acute mind I think when
people a really but I have a dream part
dr. King finished high school at 15 your
friend's colors at 19 your friends seven
similar at twenty we've got a PhD at 26
Freeman bright guy he was finishing
ahead of it I finished high school 17
but for different reasons
you just didn't go back no I just left
right yeah but but but really just says
using his time will and did you know
what my Malcolm X at all didn't uh no
American kid in the medium one time back
was out of the city
I met him basically through the book
when there is is given by Louie Lomax as
a discipline guy it's hard to compare
the two there was dr. King's church was
right in the belly of the Southern
Confederacy
right in the belly another king your
faith to change laws my rose Bob's
arrested the sound above the drivers he
had red color see if the real whites
from the front those were violated but
punched by law so the bus driver was
right technically we're wrong morally he
was rebut in a legal sense he was
correct and what can we call unjust law
does hing so his major countries when he
got through we had ended the humiliation
and an indignity back at the bus and all
of that the right to vote in fair
housing and in the one Vietnam so he
used his faith to be an agent for change
of laws as somebody who lived through as
much as you did in the civil rights
movement while Vietnam was going on
while all this was happening racial
injustice comes up so often now how does
now compared to then because a lot of
people would have you believe that it's
never been worse than it is now but it
what you're describing sounds like a lot
worse then yeah doesn't attempt to
resurrected now at that time racism as a
mother behavior was legal it's one thing
foods are not like me sitting on the
front of the bus I think we have to
leave the right to make me get up right
we made that illegal it's well-named you
do not want me to vote none who does not
me the right to vote that's that's that
that change and so that's why when I
look at Alabama play Georgia in the big
ball game I think about the rest America
is acts Houston you can't use my
restaurant
you know George Wallace saying never
never can you come us relabel kids black
and white playing ball together there
that's using uniform colorful skin color
direction of complexion that's changed
the fact that when the big race was won
in Alabama last November the the
candidate who was running against Trump
and the Confederate Confederacy more was
Tuscaloosa Alabama your resume Alabama
is a little Wallace is kicking and leak
out they were Alban is the one sees
breakthroughs in the south
or indignant and indecency and when we
vote our numbers we have the ability to
offset it case in point
therefore million blacks in the South
unregistered four million unregistered
two and a half million residents who did
not vote a high school scenes have been
inspired by the violence and the mass
killings of it so that more 17 to 21 and
701 10 to 1 so if they in fact vote
their hopes not their fears you'll have
a coalition and hobos as you have an
athletic feel and they may not be the
bright the bright morning were just only
when we can vote let me play ball
together do you think now though too cuz
a lot of times it seems like so much has
changed over the years people are
getting fired and in trouble for saying
things and I was I was very very upset
at your position when Don Imus said what
he said I was like why are they trying
to get a guy fired for a dumb joke when
somebody does something is is it now
that it's like hey here's a chance to
get this guy out and get somebody else
in maybe somebody who's black in or it
become like we think i'ma should be
fired or here's a chance to get him out
and get somebody in that position
well hey hateful rhetoric can incite
violence and that's why it's dangerous I
mean I must looked at the young women
that directors or at them as being that
beheaded and trying to demean them yeah
good to go he was replaced by more than
Joe who himself by Dennis a conservative
but a decent guy Joe Moore enjoys a good
show he's a very decent guy who is a and
then I was conservative but he's not a
bigot he's a conservative but do you
think that it was it's hateful hateful
rhetoric is one thing but do you think
that was hateful rhetoric or and he's
just one example or is it just a guy
trying to be funny and missing the mark
like weird where's the line between hey
that's truly hateful and hey this guy
was just rying to be funny mister mark I
can't draw the line I don't know what it
is I didn't know that something they
used to before they're not funny anymore
it's people come with their sense of
dignity I remember many years ago a
community cracks in jokes on the stage
there'd be funny as people arrived the
jokes always at the expense of the week
mm-hm
why and in the favor of the powerful did
you iron toast jokes funny anymore
because people are so
themselves they do not accept the fact
they're being talked down I see no no
did you never surprise I'm not very well
did you what kind of guy was a smart and
funny and caring you know I remember
when my mom Mabel I used to do her jokes
and she would say well you name a
Chinese child you drop it drop your
dishes paint paint paint paint oh that's
not funny anymore all there was crack
jokes about black women not funny
anymore because they're correct just
about Native Americans not funny anymore
so as people come into says that dignity
they don't want to be the butt of the
joke well you know moms Mabley too I
mean she was she was also you know
coming at a different era she was clean
I think it also is what you're trying to
do if you're trying to be funny and
you're trying to make someone laugh even
if it's in poor taste the attempt is to
be funny if you're trying to be hateful
I think there's a very different
you could be hateful and say it nicely
but you're still being hateful well it's
contextual it's always contextual do you
think people have lost context like the
way social media is and the way we're
kind of going after each other do you
think people look at context the way
they should
well when you make lives acceptable the
way the president tells them and when
you incite fear I mean in Virginia we
warned about 20,000 loss on the flip of
a coin it's not funny
Oh Hillary won by three million votes
three million and laws it's not funny
sometimes it's something wrong what's
wrong with that well that's the
Electoral College thing and and Hillary
I think thought that I mean she's more
familiar with it than any she and she
would say Hillary did say hey look the
results have to be respected I think she
was worried that she would lose the
popular vote and win the electoral and
and was the opposite happened look
trouble he will say he thinks that
colors he thinks was rigged
yeah he did say that was the funny part
is they both said being the opposite and
benefit from it
and so really what yeah we go one go and
and butchering this did he contest they
came down to a States right as opposed
to universal right to vote which my
father before they stopped accountant
we did not kind of twenty-seven thousand
votes in the Bell County so they loser 1
and the one loss and Hitler did win a
loss and the loser won so that that is a
crack in our system it must end what do
you think if you have a one-person
one-vote democracy in everybody
everybody's vote counts I mean look I'm
all for getting rid of the electoral
college but we all just kind of have to
agree that that's what we're doing yeah
but the big thing they're worried
California New York will have too much
of a say over smaller states but I'm all
for getting rid of you shouldn't be
punished goes to choose Loomis
California written lock and so yeah that
that's that has to do with Confederate
law how you counted people who were
enslaved the 350 man business and so
it's not a matter just numbers as a
matter of the context which was slavery
what do you attribute the division
that's going on right now in people to I
mean I feel like you know you you look
out and the opinions that people have
are as sort of divisive and combative as
I remember them being well there are
much of us do with President Trump
neither has the powder said the climate
of decency are and dignity of barbarity
he says the climate when he says the
climate that rock is not an American
citizen those who didn't vote for him
they accept that proposition which is
not true oh when he sets the climate
that supporting the Supreme Court that's
stacked it's not true it should not be
so and so's and the way he has done the
North Korea and Russia the leaders after
climate I mean when Kennedy Kennedy was
president we just felt brotherbrother
self the conditions doesn't that change
that much in verse 63 breath we felt
brother brother say you feel like you
had a guy in the White House who cared
and who
to make any better you can leave the
south and go to Rams o'clock about
McKenna Department of Justice and get
justice they're gonna go leave gotta go
to Jeff Sessions Jeff Booher grad
sessions they can further adrenaline
Confederate yeah he's a beater I'll be
honest I find him irritating
well his his point the Voting Rights Act
he said was an intrusion on the south
and intrusion yet whole counties of
blacks from the back and vote he thought
the trail government getting involved
was an intrusion
he's anti-bullying rights what do you
think I was gonna ask what do you think
about the argument that because so much
focus is put on the people like you know
I don't to bring up Imus again but the
people that are saying things and the
people in entertainment and the people
that are coming out there and publicly
using words as opposed to what you're
talking about which is the votes and the
laws and the things like that that it's
created a backlash a lot of people think
that because people feel like there's so
much punishment going on for improper
language that there's this backlash
happening and that people who disagree
with your showing it in their votes now
though some comedians go countercultural
they express a dignity all those are ass
people and I think that that kind of
really breaks down - I mean when someone
demean someone by their race to religion
that gender it's just for that wrong and
when and when a given discharge a given
ring a person has more of a pop of a
pulpit the minister does with such power
comes responsibility you cannot use this
platform to spread pain disappeared
garbage spread hurt you must choose
healing and hope over hurt and hate
though the choices you have to make and
if you don't know if people have a right
to fight back